- Lucky number seven is one that I know
I'm going to get heat for.
Please don't attack me.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I've watched a lot of medical dramas
over the last two years.
Some of them really good,
and some of them that need
a little bit of improvement.
A little bit.
And to cap off the year,
I'm gonna be ranking them
from least to most accurate.
If you disagree with me on
any of these on the list
drop it down below in the comments.
I want to know your thoughts.
Let's get started. Boop!
Number 16, the least
accurate medical drama
that I watched on this
channel is "Attaway General".
Sorry to my Dixie D'Amelio fans out there.
but the show just has inaccuracies galore.
The uniforms aren't right.
They're wearing hair nets at times.
They're having teenagers deliver
medical care as volunteers.
I literally remember
one scene when they were
trying to save someone's
life where the doctor was
like checking a pulse like this
and the EKG monitor just
has colorful strips going
across it, they mean absolutely nothing.
Just nothing makes sense on the show.
I get that it's young folks,
they're trying their first time at acting
and I support that, more power to them.
I'm strictly talking about
the medical accuracy.
Number 15, and the second
least accurate medical drama,
"Doogie Howser".
I can't believe it's this low on the list
but the reality is it's an older show,
so the medical accuracy is just not
up to par to our current standards.
Also, I really remember
this one very awkward scene.
- Doogie monster.
- Whoa!
Maybe that kind of stuff
was okay back then,
now it definitely freaked me out.
Number 14, "Nurses".
I watched it with my
good friend Nurse Bianca,
who also was heavy critical of the show.
There's just a lot of inaccuracies.
They don't follow a lot
of the medical guidelines.
Literally on the episode, they had one
of the nurses attacking another nurse
for treating someone
who is a known criminal.
We treat everybody in the medical space,
so that made no sense.
And then in another scene
they had a doctor just say,
oh, we ran out of O blood,
so I'm just going to connect
myself cause I'm O blood
and give it to the patient.
Like, no, sir, we don't do that.
That is highly inaccurate.
I'm calling BS.
I love nurses, they're
the backbone of medicine.
The show itself didn't do them justice.
Lucky 13 is "Transplant".
I really liked the premise of this one.
We have a Syrian refugee
that's thrust back into
practicing medicine in Canada.
I was really excited for it to work.
However, in the very first
scene you have an individual
who's not a doctor in Canada drilling
into someone's head in
order to save their life.
Throughout the entire episode
no one was doing chest compressions.
They were talking
about intubating people,
getting cardiac consult.
Where were the chest compressions?
Chest compressions, chest compressions,
chest compressions, folks.
For number 12, we have "Royal Pains".
The medical accuracy is
just out of this world.
It's almost like they're functioning
like an ER specialist,
family medicine doctor,
interventional cardiologist, toxicologist.
It's like they're super human.
He didn't even look at her eyes.
How does he know what
her pupils look like?
It sounds like he has x-ray vision.
He could see from across the room.
That is not how a medical
diagnosis is made,
and I feel like it misguides people
into thinking doctors
have to know right away
what's going on.
A lot of times we don't and we
have to investigate further.
By the way, all the medical
dramas I'm ranking now
and I've reviewed in the
past are linked down below,
so if you want to watch one
of those in more detail,
check it out.
Number 11, we have "The Night Shift".
I know that there's a lot of fans
on this show and they
may be upset seeing their
favorite medical drama
this low on the list.
It's just not so medically accurate.
At least to be fair, the
one episode I watched
they had one doctor
completely lose his mind.
(people snarling)
Like there was just so much
unrealistic actions happening
by the staff that it made it
feel not medically accurate.
Again, the procedures they showed,
the medical illnesses
they showed were so far
out there that you probably
wouldn't even find them
in a medical book.
It would have to be a sub
subspecialist medical book
in order to find these conditions.
Number 10, falling somewhere
in the middle of the list,
is "Nurse Jackie".
Now this show is darker
than most medical dramas on this list,
and I actually really enjoyed
the depth of the show.
However, the characters
were just so aggressive
in their illegal action.
If she forged his organ donor certificate
on the back of his license, that's crazy.
Like there's just so many
things that keep happening to
make it seem outrageous,
to make it interesting,
it doesn't feel quite realistic.
Coming in at number nine, "The Resident".
I actually got invited
by one of the cast members to be
on the set with them, got
a behind the scenes tour.
Super cool.
All that's linked down below.
I think this show falls somewhere
in the middle of the pack
when it comes to medical accuracy.
They use a lot of good medical
terms that are accurate.
Their procedures are performed
with a decent level of accuracy.
The one thing that I
will say is the residents
on the show are really
like cowboy residents.
They're doing whatever they want.
- You do whatever the hell I
tell you, no questions asked.
- So that really isn't realistic,
and just like any good medical drama,
the drama's turned up all time high.
While I dig the drama, the realism falls
somewhere right down the middle.
Definitely one I enjoy though,
and I recommend you check it out as well.
Number eight, we have "New Amsterdam".
All in all, I think it's a good show.
It's quality, it talks
about really important
systemic issues within healthcare.
While I think it takes
on important challenges,
it also does it in a very
unrealistic way at times.
- Will everyone in the
cardiac surgical department
please raise your hands.
Great, thank you. You're all fired.
Like that is not realistic.
Who's going to take care of
the patients in the meantime?
I definitely want to check
more episodes out of that show.
If you have a specific
episode of "New Amsterdam"
you want me to watch, drop it down below.
Lucky number seven is one that I know
I'm going to get heat for.
Please don't attack me.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I'm saying it now, I'm
sorry. "Grey's Anatomy".
I know, I know it's so, it's, it's not,
it's not that accurate.
I know it's the most popular medical drama
of all time probably.
And look, I've watched four
episodes of it on this channel.
I've probably watched maybe
a handful more on my own
and it's just not medically accurate.
Residents and interns are doing all sorts
of advanced procedures with no oversight,
romance around every corner
and heartbreak and drama,
and I know why so many of you love it.
I get it. I like it too, it's...
(loud smooching)
But still, medical accuracy,
just, it's not there.
For number six, we have "Scrubs".
Yes, the famous, famous
satirical medical show "Scrubs".
I honestly struggled with this one.
I didn't know where to place it.
I know many of you at home, on forums,
say "Scrubs" is the most accurate show.
However, I do think that it is an accurate
satirical explanation of what happens,
or representation of what
happens in hospitals,
but it is not medically accurate.
- Get her to open her mouth,
take a handful and throw it at her.
Whatever sticks, that's
the correct dosage.
- And it's a comedy, so I
get why they're doing it
and I enjoy watching it,
but one of the things
that kind of irks me with the show
maybe because I'm so
defensive and protective
of my patients is I feel like they're mean
to their patients sometimes.
And I know it's a joke
but somehow it just gets in here for me.
Number five, we have "Chicago Med".
A lot of these shows really
just focus on doctors
and "Chicago Med" really does a great job
at showing nurses as
part of the medical team.
The episode that I watched
I couldn't find almost anything
medically wrong with it.
It has good medical terminology,
the procedures that
they're doing are accurate,
and the fact that they had a nurse
telling a resident how to do
chest compressions properly,
they were critiquing them,
that got me hyped.
Number four, we have "Code Black".
This is the surprising one on the list.
The dark horse, the
black sheep, if you will.
I really fell in love with this show.
It actually genuinely upset me
to find out it was canceled.
The show felt like it was
written by medical professionals,
and then someone added a little drama,
as opposed to someone
that writes medical dramas
and then they sprinkled
some medicine into it.
I think that the real hard hitting truth
about the show is it does a good job
at showing character development
of medical professionals.
The stresses we have,
the struggles we have,
how we go about losing patients
and talking with patients.
I think those were very
real and clearly scripted
by someone who's gone
through that process.
Let's bring it back.
Let's resurrect "Code
Black". Who's with me?
Number three, we have "House MD".
I know so many House fans
wanted him to be number one,
and while the show has
incredible scientific rigor,
like it talks about true
scientific conditions,
a lot of the zebra
conditions that we've talked
about on this channel, ones
that warrant more attention.
And while I think that's great,
I think the way that my
man House MD goes about it
is just reckless.
- I want to check for Erdheim-Chester.
- How does he know what that is?
I've never even heard of it.
He's funny, he's interesting, he's wacky.
He argues with people,
but also the residents
and the fellows that are with him,
they each bring their own
unique spin on the show.
So I'm a huge fan.
I want to watch more
episodes of "House MD"
and I have it third on my list.
I wonder where it falls on yours.
We're at the top two folks,
it's getting serious.
The competition is heating up.
Number two is "The Good Doctor".
Dr. Shaun comes in with the accuracy.
The big thing, a true medical
professional, who is diagnosed
with autism, but is still
doing their job phenomenally.
When they talk about medical conditions,
the way that they talk about it
in a reasonable, easy to understand way,
but still using medical
terminology is awesome.
I love that they manage to inject humor
even some of the most dark spots.
- Do you need me to listen to you anymore?
- No, Shaun.
- That's how real life works.
That's how medicine works.
I actually just watched the
good doctor COVID-19 episode.
That's linked down below.
Well worth a watch.
Number one, king of medical dramas,
at least in medical accuracy,
at least in my book,
it is two letters, "ER".
That's right folks.
It's an oldie, but it's
a classic. It's so good.
20, 30 years later since its inception,
it's still bingeable.
It's still quality.
It still tells real life
stories about humans.
The issues that we run into hospitals
to this very day still apply
to the episodes that are found in ER.
It's truly one of my
favorite medical dramas.
The medical accuracy is really solid.
Don't get me wrong.
They sometimes go overboard
and they make diagnoses too
quickly or too dramatically.
But the accuracy, the heart of the show,
especially with how long
the show has been around,
how many careers it's
made, George Clooney,
it's number one in my books.
I know you want to disagree with me.
I know you have other thoughts,
and I want to hear your thoughts.
Hit me in the comments down below.
Tell me what your list looks like.
Tell me which one of
these you disagree with,
'cause I genuinely want to know.
If you love one of these medical dramas
and you want me to watch
a specific episode,
don't hesitate to drop
that in the comments too.
I really enjoy all these medical dramas,
so I'm linking them
all down below for you.
Or you can just click
on this playlist here for my
entire Doctor Reacts series.
There's medical dramas in
here, untold stories of the ER,
and so many more, click here,
and as always stay happy at home.
(relaxing music)